items with the offensive board that's
what he really does well for okc
one of the top offensive rebounders in
the league dort gonna try another one
this one falls
but these last two possessions resulting
in a couple of threes
[Applause]
this time dort drives it in nice move
inside
points well lou dort selects not to take
the three instead whenever this one
takes on the lakers friday night on espn
dort
that's his second three ball that he
connected on here in the first half
he embraces that type of challenge
dort made his last three at what point
mark do you
adjust your defensive scheme to maybe
close out on him a little harder now
paul
and alexander who are proven to win ball
games but
his job that's a whole lot of room his
job is to step in with confidence
and shoot the basketball to his credit
in the ball game for okc been quiet so
far here
in the first half just two points
dort okay i asked you last time when do
you adjust your defense to close out a
little stronger
i'm get coming in the game seven these
are the shots i've taken yesterday all
day
and before the game today and this
morning oklahoma city leading by
four doritos scored 10 of their last 13.
kill just alexander with a little bit of
sauce the dime inside and dort
with another bucket players are
delivering the basketball they're not
looking at him like he's a liability
they're putting him in position to score
black folks were
killed in that massacre when a white mob
stormed that area
he's rarely or rarely is that story told
as dortmund
hits the outside jump shot shots
and this is a big basket the way the
offense was going for the thunder to
impact this ball game
he's one for seven from downtown noel
wanted the lob it wasn't high enough
dort inside
great pump fake for the bucket and he's
up to 23 points now in the game
chris paul on the drive by inside tort
off the nice time by chris paul got
numbers because covington is trailing
the play
dort open lou dort ties the game
at 99.